hello Internet it's all time here again
Sony have a conference and parts is this
something we're gonna get used to saying
every year now there's so many
conferences every single year and now I
guess the PlayStation experience is on
align well this is like the one fine
PlayStation conference but post games
Coast compost e3 post Gamescom yeah TGS
posted yes free Blizzcon eventually
we'll get one every other week so I
never happens to stop this cycle of
security even though this is another
conference labor on top of all our other
conferences there was no shortage of new
information to talk about so we have
this special stream today to talk about
everything we've seen at the Sony
conference at Paris games week and I
guess let's start with what they showed
off first which was the call of duty
zombies spin-off the giant what is this
mic so that's the Sony exclusive like
kind of story driven zombie stuff I
guess I mean all the zombies kind of
have their own stories but the one
coming for all my songs only feel well
it's the continuation like this is a
zombie story we've gotten since the
first game yeah and continuing those
characters and going on as opposed to
the the other standalone war story which
we've seen more trailers of and has some
more like some of the bigger actors yes
the shadows of evil is the one that's
like 1930s kind of it's Ron Perlman is
voicing one who looks like a Jeff
Goldblum great play I played that pretty
extensively and it's it's weird to hear
Jeff Goldblum just talking about zombies
he's always got his you know dulcet
tones I don't know he's kind of very mod
yeah in a weird way this is kind of what
like a lot of people have been talking
about for a while which is like when it
is um be is going to take over like it's
it's become such a popular part of the
main franchise and do you think this is
like a step in that direction Justin uh
you know I don't know that it's
necessarily taking over like I think
it's always been a big part of of what
Call of Duty is and this is just kind of
feeding into that like you want that the
main Call of Duty experience and that's
you have to call the game Call of Duty
but you also want that something like
this armies are just that fun addition
and I think it's more saying this is
something you're always gonna get don't
worry we're not going to take the
way but and it's not just like a small
add-on like this is its own separate
thing do you could it be its own game
though like I almost feel like it could
like this could be the fourth the set of
Call of Duty other fit what the fifth
one at this point maybe then its
franchise maybe this is then testing the
waters because even saying that okay
we're gonna make this sort of like you
know expansion or whatever you want to
call us and specifically about the
zombies this sort of like showing that
they're they're knee-deep in the dead is
it work
yeah they're taking it seriously by the
looks of it so was this an expansion
pack is this standalone is this what the
hell is this
well so and so it's kind of one of those
weird in-between things it is fine it
what is an expansion what does DLC it is
downloadable content it doesn't fit
directly into the main game I mean you
still have black ops series its own
standalone experience but you have to
own black ops 3 play this yeah it's not
like this is not a separate game that
you're gonna be able to buy and purchase
I think those right now it's a pre-order
bonus when you get it through Game Stop
or certain retailers or are offering
this as here's your pre-order bonus I'm
sure there's gonna be a way to get it
down the line outside of pre-ordering
yeah like they always hopefully not too
expensive though down the line because
it's a little bit strange if they're
gonna release this big thing that's
substantial on its own and say but you
also have to buy this full game to get
it when it's totally detached from it
and almost weird that they're announcing
it now before the game has come out it
seems like a PlayStation experience kind
of an answer inch but maybe the
Parisians really love zombies like you
excited about playing this uh yeah
that's specifically I mean I have a few
friends that get Treyarch scald duties
specifically for zombies don't touch
like barely touch multiplayer and camp
let alone campaign but it's always fun
to jump online and kind of there's so
many secrets throughout these and it's
fun too it's one of those things you
really have to master because these get
hard you play zombies in the other games
and it you get to around seven and
you're dying I mean that was the thing
about the gameplay they were showing
today there were four times I saw it
looked like they were just about to die
but it still looked cool but yeah I'm
always excited for the zombies more so
than the other modes
interventioning secrets like people are
still finding secrets from some of the
earlier unit wasn't yeah there was that
secret recently where somebody found
like oh if you put the gnome in this
specific spot and then a cup I can't
remember exactly what it was do you know
what I'm talking about I know what
you're talking about I don't know
specifically what it was but yeah it's
crazy that that was
what black ops I think black ops 1 talk
ops 2 but because yeah but it's crazy
that there's so many hidden things I
mean it took me a few weeks to start to
master even like der riese the third one
that ever came out for world at war yeah
that's the first one there were really a
lot of branching paths and you get the
pack-a-punch machine you like upgrade
the weapons they showed it briefly in
this gameplay today just makes the guns
insane but I remember just being
astounded at how many different ways
they were to approach that cool a lot
more stuff to look forward to every
zombie fans then let us know what you
think yeah you look forward to playing
some more Call of Duty let us know in
the comment box below alright we got a
bunch of more things to talk about
project Morpheus it was called before
it's been renamed Sony VR and today we
got a bunch more information about games
for it but not necessarily the big crazy
reveal of date or price we're looking
forward to Peter you're a V or person
dujour what do you think about what's
not you should know it off today I think
they're taking some smart moves when it
comes with the initial offerings because
kind of beating a dead horse here but
games you make for VR are best when
they're made for of you are from the
start and a lot of it has to do is sort
of mimicking the real world in the game
so you're sitting in a chair it's the
same as sitting in a cockpit or sitting
in a car so to have Gran Turismo sport
announced for VR makes a lot of sense
they showed that other game which was
sort of like a you were those like those
suits and it was like a sport Riggs
Riggs Walker but you know and then they
showed off stuff like a Valkyrie again
it's in a short little trailer that one
looks so I came looks so promising and
I've played it loved it and I think a
lot yeah there we go so like a lot of
these little experiences are gonna be
really good
they also showed off the zone battle
zone which is a it's taking like an old
like vector based PC game and bringing
that which was kind of nice for me
because I used to play that a lot as a
kid Robbie yeah German bobbins in the
journey which is uh it kind of looked
like destiny with that little character
flitting around portal portal or portal
tour yeah I guess you're right yeah I
mean we also got until dawn and Tekken
and like it is seconds a weird one
i I'm really curious how Tekken is gonna
work in virtual yeah what if they did
like a first-person fighting them be
and you put on a vest and so you have to
get a punch maybe too optimistic but I
mean I think that will be an interesting
experiment and it's a safe experiment
because you know it's it's so clearly a
gimmick that they're not trying to say
oh this is this grand new VR experience
it's like it's Tekken do you want to try
it in VR where does the wonder was
Christ Tech are doing yes presumably
they want to you know that their engine
salesman at this stage more than
anything else so presumably they want to
be able to show off that hey also our
engine can do the or stuff at the box
yeah they've been working I believe
within video for a while to have the
hardware work with our engine really
well but back in d3 I tried a demo where
you are sort of scaling a cliff and you
know you crane your neck up as you would
when you're climbing a cliff and
eventually if you like look down because
things fall and I believed I was going
to like get eggs from a dinosaur model
or something like that it was a fine
little demo I have I'm curious as to you
but this whole experience is gonna be
like how big they're gonna make it
because these experiences especially
when it's trying to be immersive have to
be so everything has to be considered
for and taken into account in terms of
the environment in the atmosphere to
make a full game that does all those
little things to make it work well in VR
it's gonna be expensive so maybe
Robinson will just be sort of like a
small demo that will prove to other
companies use our tech but it's not
going to be the problem if we keep
getting these small demos like until
dawn rush of blood like I get where
they're dipping back because I guess
that name has the surprising amount of
cash a actually at this stage people who
as well-received but isn't it kind of a
problem like we're still talking about
these little side project game no I
don't sound a problem at all VR is is so
young I mean look like look back to it
you know any game console in the 70s and
80s and look at those tiny games and say
isn't it a problem that we only have you
know pong isn't this where is the bigger
you know I this tech will mature over
time people's efficiency to develop for
VR will improve over time so we're at
the early stage I don't think this is a
problem they need to get small things in
consumers hands because people will not
be ready to do a 50 hour game right if
you straight away the bat only the 5
hour game like I'd want an experience
that I can sit and I can get through the
entirety and then maybe share with a
friend and that's the other thing that's
important is like the art us talking
about it and just like seeing videos of
it
doesn't sell it you have to try it and
if you have an experiences like oh yeah
I got for the first five minutes of this
game I'm not sure how much it's gonna
how much better it's gonna be
whereas here's a self-contained five
minute experience like yeah it's perfect
yeah like the Danny's demo at Gamescom
when we did the oculus touch oh yeah
completely the thing I mean just
watching your reactions in that it was
like it seemed like before I didn't know
how excited you were when you're in it
it was like no question he's loving this
right now and that's just to say like
things like the Walker here this is a
great way way to get people who wouldn't
play games as well to sort of have an
experience with VR and be understand its
power yeah I mean at least maybe that
games in the traditional sense we're
gonna think of complex hardcore games
but interactive media where you are you
know putting yourself into the
experience in one way or another Mike do
you do you think you would rather do
this or be put in a virtual reality pit
of snakes oh my god neither - snakes not
have choices about the heights I'm
terrified of heights but snakes are
worse but yeah that that is an
experience I'd probably want to try I
don't know how long it lasts before I
yeah I might like to start shaking
uncontrollably I get secondhand fear of
heights - just seeing someone else
Oh like the balconies at like really big
theaters I can't see someone sit next to
the edge and I grab him hold onto him I
just have a big 90 inch projection
screen and I played Assassin's Creed 1
and my dad walked up side and when nope
Justin final point on vor though do you
think if we didn't see a release date
under price today we're gonna have to
see the PlayStation experience or maybe
2016 I we're seeing so many games and
that means that they're gonna be there
close to market like they they're
showing an experience that you're gonna
be able to purchase soon so we have to
have an a release date no price and I
think we're gonna hear that a place to
experience a PlayStation experience I
think one of the reasons is that are
holding off it's because it's gonna be
really [ __ ] expensive yeah I mean
oculus they've already said like no
we're not gonna be able to hit that same
DevKit price point when you look at the
hololens which is you know very
different experience a very
self-contained thing that's several
thousand doors close to $10,000 hololens
is also a way off that I mean the the
price that they're quoting for that now
isn't is not anything that we should
consider
but Sony's other VR experience of like
there are other wraparound headset
that's over $1,000
that was free market that misunderstood
where technology is right now that was
for I'm a rich person I'm gonna buy a
$1,200 headset great lets me see a 70
inch screen that's like their high-end
television kind of stuff yeah it's got
that Sony is is that's a whole different
section of Sony that made that it's just
luxury [ __ ] this is the luxury
bullsh yeah this is like this is going
to be you know they're targeting
mass-market stuff with us sorry are we
giving mass-market but they have said
that this is basically a standalone
console this is its own standalone
experience and I mean not in the sense
that you can only buy this you'll still
need a PlayStation 4 but that they're
not gonna target this as like here's a
$50 accessory this is of course no but
but it but the hardware could be
subsidized by the game sales right the
same way that they sold PlayStation 3 at
a loss to begin with wasn't a great idea
but that was down to manufacturing
issues which complicated the whole
scenario here if they can say look we
have an install base we're going to be
releasing games for it people seem to be
liking it they're gonna be okay taking a
bit of a loss if it can recoup that
money the software it's good I think
they're gonna do that yeah it's going to
be just to see what price point they
learn that because it's been nine years
since e3 2006 but yeah let us know what
you think of Sony VR and what they
showed off at Paris games week what
price point you'd be willing to stretch
to to get in on the VR revolution let us
know in the comment box below all right
a lot more stuff showing off there were
so many trailers shown at this press
conference and in this section we're
gonna concentrate on what we're looking
forward to playing next year 2016 only a
couple of months left so you don't
really have that much in the con for the
rest of 2015 but looking forward towards
2016 a lot of things to get excited
about Justin first of all what were some
of the games that jumped out to you the
Sony showed off the way it was so long
oh my God look at this skirt okay this
is the list of games that we have
currently that I have to know get
through notice Danny's using a mouse
with his laptop because the trackpad is
broken
bollocks it was you know it's great
going into having these experiences that
don't feel super new but I do like the
mix of old technology and new with
something like horizon zero dawn yeah
like that looked really cool that big
dinosaur
oh and we've seen that before and I feel
like we've seen it from a different
standpoint this time like she was taking
down the dinosaur in a different way
yeah that looked really awesome yeah
that's a that's an interesting-looking
game and a couple of one of a couple of
stage demos and that we got looks
beautiful as well
yeah it reminds me of what was that
third person vanquished she reminds me
of vanquishing something especially she
has like a little slide maneuver that
she does where it she likes I don't know
they're gonna show it here she comes
rockets on our ankles no but she slides
on her knees for like way longer than
momentum dictates oh yeah that was kind
of that reminded me of anguish for sure
what I don't understand is why is she
wearing furs but fighting things that
shoot lasers and his fully armored
beautifully if she's you know pulling
off armor and things from their wood
chips well maybe some plate knob because
like they hate the machines right
because the technologies what killed
their forefathers like [ __ ] it I'm gonna
wear mink and another game and all about
exploring weird and wonderful world so
we finally got a release date for was
Nolan sky it's coming at in June 2016
III time yeah excited about that one
Mike yeah excited bird no man's sky
furred just like a lot of people for a
long time and every time they push it
back or they just kind of a hazy on one
that's gonna release ice you know so you
see Shaun Murray was tweeting yesterday
or something he's like they were really
sorry that we can't be more specific but
we really don't want to screw this up we
really want to nail it and I agree with
my I just say take your time and bring
it out so we can enjoy when it comes out
and it looks every time I see it it just
makes me want to play it more just kind
of that pure exploration without too
much intent kind of like a bethesda game
almost like those kind of sand boxes I'm
still I'm still curious as to whether
Nomad sky will have enough substance to
the exploration to it'd like keep me
coming back yeah but just I got like a
purely that maybe like a week or two of
just exploring sounds awesome so I'm I'm
glad I'll be able to have that like at
the end of the busy spring season and
the voiceovers Rutger Hauer is that his
name I don't know a guy from Blade
Runner and also hobo with a shotgun if
every 27th we got our sorry for every
16th we got our release date for Street
Fighter 5 as well helliya dhalsim's in
the game yeah who would have known and
six other characters which we don't
really know who they are
this air Tate's figured that I have yet
there was no there what's up data mining
yesterday I checked thought they found
Ibuki and jury character data ok
I'm the beta so maybe let's talk about
the way you unlock these characters
though because it's kind of by fighting
in the streets by using fight money yeah
yeah yeah tell me about fight money
I remember when used to play fighting
games and you beat Arcade Mode and it
would like unlock a new character yeah
yeah so there it's sort of like that
where you're not using DLC or anything
else you're playing the game to unlock
new characters the set on the right no
that looks like Dudley Oh
Tommy gun on the last second in from the
left that looks like a boxer Honda
Apollo sorry fight anyway money yeah so
for some reason there's an in-game
currency I don't know what why you need
that but that's how you unlock new
characters that's not DLC it's you know
they're essentially avoiding the folly
of what they did with Street Fighter
cross Tekken where they had characters
on the disk and and then they released
it as DLC yeah so to play devil's
advocate do you think they can implement
microtransactions for the fight money
yeah yeah and they are they won't go
there I'm sure they're yeah 100% that's
what I was but it but if I mean look
like I think Street Fighter fans will
play the game enough you know the build
is sort of unlike people who really like
Street Fighter will play it enough and
they'll eventually just unlock enough
money sure I don't think it's the sort
of game where like five hours in you're
gonna think man I'm bored I need to like
get something new out of this experience
final throwdown 10 bucks yeah maybe if
you're super curious but I I think this
you know this game lends itself to long
play sessions anyway so yeah I'm
personally not too worried about micro
transactions go that's me a couple of
other games mentioned as well let's see
if they take us on these vector no
Prelude a BG of energies can replant
sorry BG yeah sorry and matter foal
which is the new oh yeah house mark
house mark resogun the best launch game
on the ps4
yes great this looks very much like CG
trailer for a more indie looking game
though right
a little bit yeah but no shooter maybe
is what its gonna be yeah it's going to
be probably a great action game that
people will love there you go I heard it
here first folks
uncharted 4 we saw another little
trailer some of the most similar players
well that trailer was kind of BS to me
let me through that thing in a bit
El Dorado graphic it's from the other
fortune yeah that was really cool yeah
oh yeah oh yeah they're doing all the
supernatural elements but yeah they
weren't the idea but the trailer was
showing gameplay looks like I was from
one perspective to the last it's like
this is not what the experience is gonna
be like you are a camera flying through
a pre-scripted battle be good to see all
the curioso Liam Drake I was like
writing our news story and I kept typing
game plans like wait a minute I wasn't
gameplay no it's just footage it's just
humans murdering each other it's great
anyone can be a little savage but a game
that actually works like actually say in
real time is very different yeah shoot
that lady there's something weird about
them wearing like more civilian clothes
that sort of makes it a little bit more
gross strange right well my Marie he's a
soldier that's good
someone's just wearing gap I guess yeah
exactly face I'll be surprised if there
was like some sort of brought to you by
Banana Republic let's just remind you
that Drake is a homicidal maniac who
murders everyone he needs yeah him and
Lara Croft's we've got a real good body
count game going on there and let's move
on to the latest fever dream from Media
Molecule and actually yeah in name as
well almost dreams so people when we
were watching these in the in the office
some people were really freaked out by
the imagery because yeah there you have
the it was more like pants what I would
like this very Guillermo del Toro kind
of dreamscapes I love it like I thought
that looked really cool like I really
want to get apartment be a part of this
whereas I was sitting next to Randolph
Ramsey who's our managing editor and he
was like nope nope this is night then
not in your fuel it's a real close to
being super creepy I experienced this
every night already I don't know and I
wake up in a sweat and like I get too
close and spiders yeah I promise all of
you it's not fun but I'm just kidding I
know this looks interesting yeah
the that whole like six axis or whatever
it's got it's this right fingers how can
that be creepy look it's just again in
the door cute it's it's Harry Potter
meets garam al del Toro meets - Mickey
Mouse look forward to playing nightmares
maybe next year I just hope we there's
no date on this yet so next year and
beyond as some betas coming next year
battle born and there's no conveyed
apparently coming to
console first and then we also got news
of the new GT game Gran Turismo sport of
which there will be a beta next year as
well yeah what she got that bad boy I
really like the Gran Turismo series I
didn't like six very much five was
pretty good but six just went too deep
into the like microtransaction thing for
yeah but you know I this is one series I
just I loved also because what it like
represents which is this like this weird
like search for like high tech and when
it comes out it's always just like oh
this is pretty great but it's not like
super futuristic but it's it's like a
silly little series though like it's got
this like horrible UI yes you know like
it takes itself way too seriously but I
really like the way it controls
traditionally and I like their their
particular attention to detail so I'm
looking forward to that and the fact
that's gonna be in VR that's pretty cool
mmm-hmm probably not the best way to
play it but probably a fun experience so
do you think that this game will come
out first or that we will put a manned
mission to Mars probably coincide on the
same day I mean if they're talking about
it like it is kind of a it's not really
pulling this thing to say oh we're going
to have a you know beta within six
months of of this happening Bush I mean
what's coming look I mean no prologue
this time yeah there's been a lot of
Gran Turismo games that fell victim to
delays but between five and six wasn't
that long so how many forts of games
will come at I would I'll bet
at least three cuz there been three
since the last Grand Turismo yeah yes
including her well a lot of good games
coming out next year we have one Sony
game coming out this year driveclub
bikes like that's their answer like Xbox
has been pushing like no we have a great
2015 we're gonna talk about 2016 soon
but you got
rise the Tomb Raider got some halo
what's butch PlayStation got we're
adding bikes to that like driveclub is
just the middle-aged man who's having
like you know midlife crisis thinks
motorcycles gonna solve everything
throwing money at it yeah it's currently
available on the PlayStation Store and I
don't think this is an expansion I think
this is a yet is a new standalone
experience so you can pay real world
money for this later
right now why are you watching this you
could be buying driveclub bikes I've no
idea watching us
finally having to try and see if I can
see what the cost is that's what I'm as
soon as this is finished I'm gonna go
it's it's 15 euro so it's probably 15
dollars in that case there you go
go play it why aren't you playing it yet
are you playing it no all right well if
you're not playing that there's lots of
good Sony PlayStation 4 games coming out
in 2016
let us know what you thought of as
Sony's and all the games they showed off
today boards falling out of my mouth
like David cage we didn't talk about
that actually it's not coming out next
year no all right let us know what you
think of as Sony's 2016 lineup in the
comment box below alright our last
segment for today's Paris games week
Sony and wrap up is all about not what
they showed but what they didn't show
just a notable omission for you oh yeah
there are so many things you wanted to I
wanted to see and some things you know
we're not gonna be there Michael and
cell comes out you know like I I know
he's gonna talk about the game he's
already talking about malarum role be of
the young good and evil to never I know
it's never gonna happen I know that
every time every time he comes out on
stage I just I want it oh yeah and he
probably wants to talk about it as well
oh he wants to talk about like oh yeah
this has been cancelled this isn't gonna
happen what a big game is we thought
were counseled on how and not counseled
any more Last Guardian no sign of us in
person that in TGS there was there was
nothing new I mean they had the big they
had that big screen that had the Treecko
monster come down but there was no
actual new gameplay that was the exact
same demo that we saw from e3 not here
at Paris at all like I bet they're
showing the same demo on the TV screen
yeah the last few not to film it because
they've heard he ship it and one thing
they didn't show at the conference that
I saw previously tweeted was heavy rain
coming to PlayStation 4 I saw Quantic
Dream tweeting that in the morning
know another thing these to me no really
all right check Twitter again make sure
knots not there's a really great YouTube
video that if you guys have after you're
done watching this you should check out
a YouTube video of heavy rain
a blooper where all this guy does is
fail as
chasing a guy through a supermarket it's
the funniest thing it is heavy rain in a
nutshell yeah have your MPs for shown at
Paris games week apparently exactly is
that a real account is that a real
account who knows you can go find out
yourself most of the games price is
following it so I hope so and another
game that was a lots of song and dance
about it at e3 and then they'll take
shown here at Shenmue 3 there's no
surprises there's nothing to show for
that game but there's like hey look it
got funded whoo they could at least see
that I could do that but I think of all
the weird press they've been getting
like after that whole funding round and
the other coming back and saying we
needed more money right like that I
think they're trying to avoid that until
they actually have some like really
interesting gameplay to show off we're
gonna talking about for like immediately
after 3 got funded they're like yeah
we're also planning it at some point
doing for chill out Dookie let's take us
one step at a time
easy bastard he's got a lot of
enthusiasm I love the enthusiasm
oh peter mullan you had that as well
yeah and everyone loves his enthusiasm
and nothing from Santa Monica um God of
War you're confused about that
well I wouldn't say confused I was
expecting some more God of War because
we got the God of War Collection
Jesus God would say it's about time for
a new God of War so this isn't tired
we're gonna get this PlayStation
experience I'm I'm betting PlayStation
experience new God of War the crate
doesn't better look different and be a
different I mean I sure know I'm so old
and tired at this point like we've just
he's done so much well there's no one
left the murder nor if you could go some
Norse we're gonna go for like
judeo-christian God's next I'm just say
Uncharted cross God of War yeah yeah I
can mesh those two I think I wish they'd
show more blood-borne maybe yeah
obviously this close to the expansions
release I wish they showed they didn't
show anything new it was just more they
were showing like the saw blade attacks
and everything which is gonna be awesome
when you actually get to play it but
short trailer it seemed like most about
it already and shown though right yeah
it was more of yeah TGS stuff yeah I
just I I can't wait for this this I'm
looking forward to this just as much as
some games coming out this fall and lash
and I think I was really hoping for
something more just because it's what
November 24th I think mm-hmm it's
you know impending oh yeah they would
have done some sort of decision you
don't know spoil it too much maybe yeah
I guess so I can respect that but show
me more than this eyeball throat Justin
Ryan you were talking about
so rhyme is a game that looks absolutely
beautiful and we didn't see it at e3
this year either and it's kind of like a
Zelda type adventure and it was I think
a PlayStation 4 exclusive and it's just
been missing for them over a year now
and they showed it at Gamescom like two
years ago
yeah and that was the only time we've
we've seen anything from it looks
wonderful like oh I was really looking
forward to this game it's like the Wind
Waker but not a place to like update in
like oh this is gonna be great and it's
still gone any idea where that was being
developed was it a European game perhaps
they might keep her for PlayStation
experience then yeah maybe I guess it
just if it was shown at Gamescom you
would have thought then maybe it was the
European studio yeah the like Paris
would have been the great time to bring
this back I think people like myself
remember it and they want to see more
hmm what happened and last time our list
of games not shown is it surprising we
didn't see any final fantasy no I think
a little bit like this is a such a
PlayStation focus show like even just a
little bit more I Final Fantasy 7 we're
not gonna hear more about Final Fantasy
7 because they literally I like I think
people were surprised on the development
side when they said yeah Final Fantasy 7
remake it's coming oh I guess we should
start on that all right really
we're not gonna see that for a while but
some department that's only knew about
that and nobody else did
but unlike a trailer for Final Fantasy
15 maybe yeah but they've done so much
on that game over the past six months I
feel like they've good they've gone over
so much minutiae about how it works you
know apart from spoiling stuff I don't
know what's left to show show me bikes I
want to see all for those people on
bicycles or customization options for
the roller
driveclub X Final Fantasy put some like
flames on my car check it out trick it
out I'll be Michael riders beaten like
mixin GTA DLC gosh putting some speakers
not I can hear Justin on the phone right
now or sorry so Sony on the phone right
now looking for you to sign up at all
your sick ideas so I guess Lobby
so some of the stuff do we think we'll
see out the PlayStation experience is
not burning oh definitely like for the
final I were definite
see some final fantasy we're definitely
gonna get a confirmation of Beyond Good
and Evil definitely gonna get god I
think god of war more some more Final
Fantasy less Guardian I think there
could be less card I think there could
be less I think it got a little more
time after this released it release date
for Last Guardian well we don't too much
longer the way December 5th and 6 just
down the road and Moscone Center is the
PlayStation experience but for fans of
Sony video game consoles there was
plenty to enjoy today let us know what
you missed on today's stream or what you
enjoyed most in a comment box below and
that's our little wrap-up show done and
dusted and final thoughts gents and what
was the most impressive thing you saw
today on the show Peter first generally
just sort of the variety of experiences
that are coming to PlayStation 4 and
including PlayStation VR I think yeah
there's a lot of sequels that there are
some sequels that were being shown but
it's just great to see like new and
interesting ideas from lots of different
places converging on you know one
console and that could be also said for
Xbox one and PC but I'm just happy to
see it's also happening on PlayStation 4
just some thoughts I I'm just amazed
that they haven't let it die that I'm
still seeing all these great new titles
for the PlayStation Vita
oh my favorite console is basically
saying it's not dead don't worry
yeah now the world wasn't even mentioned
today nope
do not make those it doesn't there's no
first party games making development
right now oh really good yeah it's
dun-dun-duh sit it's a legacy cause it's
your cross-play machine that yeah yeah
Mike what about yourself yeah in general
I'm glad that they're they're still
having like you know a lot of games come
out 2016 because their fall is kind of
actually weak compared to microsoft
today's Halo 5 the 10th is rise the Tomb
Raider mind exclusive but might as well
be for the fall holiday season just an
Xbox one exclusive and then I'm glad
that Sony has like pretty good deep
roster coming on 2016 like most of it
seems semi early yeah you know like
before June is a nomad sky is the latest
one I think or let me they the one that
they have release dates for I think yeah
we don't know when David pages Detroit
just put your hands up for college human
2017 at the earliest day si yeah it's
have you seen ex machina sorry not there
thanks Mike I mean basis yeah it picks
us like
right where that movie left yeah you
should check that out before this video
game spoils it um yeah it looks it's
interesting to see that they're
literally taking this one though because
so many of the tech dem was they used
for previous games were not actually
tied to the main plot of the game like
the heavy rain lady sitting with the cup
of tea thing was not that wasn't a
character that was in the game
afterwards whereas this actually looks
like they kind of stuck to it though
matically in a weird way or maybe you're
gonna be the person like chasing after
or trying to find her oh yeah the
property play many many different people
who all have QuickTime events sex scenes
right the game yeah it looks pretty good
though right of course
Detroit's looking well Detroit is
looking better than ever and Demi
whatever that's where you know the
future of manufacturers so I was saying
like this is actually realistic I bet
it's gonna be tied in to global warming
San Francisco is gonna be engulfed in
San Francisco Seattle can be destroyed
by rising tides New York mostly gone
everyone's gonna move inland and so this
is realistic and that will all move to
Detroit and it will be the future Haven
of America great and then all humans
will get together and beat up androids
like that guy really really hates
Androids because they killed his dog
right Patrick
yeah all right
thanks so much to everyone in the back
merry cash Eric Tay da Shaw died mejor
ik they miss anyone
God God always thanks to God sorry crate
I was going to kill you we're done for
this strable we'll be back at 2 p.m.
Pacific for the regularly scheduled the
lobby and so we shall see you guys then
take care and see you in 19 minutes
ha ha ha